hey this is Esther Dean I'm at BuzzFeed
and today I'm gonna read some of your
burning questions first question what
inspired you to write S&M so it's so
funny cuz it was on a Sunday I had a saw
years ago costs make me I wrote it for
Britney Spears years ago and then I had
to soak up theme park of love it's like
don't you want to ride on the pony and
everybody was like Esther this is before
a room boys wear everything those are
too much of dirty songs and then all of
a sudden as they don't come out who was
wrong
have you ever become good friends with
an artist after songwriting process if
so which one I friends with everyone see
but I'm that kind of friend to don't go
telling people your friends I'm not
telling you I'm friends with Beyonce for
what they know your business like that's
this art business
me and Rihanna that's our business be
friends it's our business though you
know because because when people think
that you're friends with them they want
to know stuff nosy what's the current
status of your solo music career I need
let me tell you something true about me
I'm a multi-talented songwriter right
and that doesn't mean like I'm giving
myself props I write so many different
songs I write pop songs rap songs R&B
songs EDM songs I write so many songs
that I can't tell which one I should
give you guys for me so I decided to
just give songs so I'm just gonna keep
on giving something so my solo music
career is just gonna come with a lot of
songs which new songwriter are you
loving and why Victoria Monet and Taylor
packs I love them so much and blue Jun I
love all of actually I'd like
songwriters are my girls so girl power I
read that you developed a sex toy called
rude boy named after your first number
one song by Rihanna what was it like to
develop a sex toy you know what it would
have been great but there was already a
sex toy in the UK called
rude boy so I didn't get to do that
Oh what is it like being a judge on
sunland I love me because it finally
gives me an opportunity to give back to
new songwriters you there's no place
that a songwriter can mentor you into a
situation that you actually win unless
you sign a deal with them and all that
stuff so I feel like it's a blessing and
it's a service to be able to actually
you know be able to be a judge on song
lengths if I get there work with my kind
some of people what is it like being a
black woman in the Sun right industry I
think it's just full of black women in a
song break its dick up it's all of us
it's a sisterhood everybody I know
that's in the music industry there's a
black woman so anyway what it is a lot
of good stuff what's your typical
songwriting process start from the start
from to finish right you wanted me to
tell you the whole thing okay I'm gonna
make some hot dogs I'm gonna get a
heater I'm gonna get a bunch of coffee
I'm gonna start around 8 o'clock I'm
gonna talk my engineers head off about
all my problems and I'm gonna tell them
everything that I've been going through
and then finally when I feel like he
can't take it anymore I'll say let's
start right now and I'll just start
writing songs about everything I told
him about and he goes home to her it's
so funny because at home should I record
at home so I'll literally record til I'm
dead tired and then he still has to stay
up like 3 to 4 hours just mixing it so
I'll start at 8:00 we'll be done at 6
o'clock in the morning but he has to
stay at least three more hours just
competent edited I love engineers people
should write a book about engineers it's
a hard job what's the craziest thing
you've done to inspire and write a song
that became a hit
I have imaginary relationships with
people so I can get like mojo you know
like what would he do or what how would
that work and then I use all that
emotion and I write songs about him
and then when I finally get the
opportunity to be with that person I
like you
I think imagination keeps me young that
I like daydream about these awesome men
and then I write songs about them and
then I meet them and then I'd be like I
don't really like you and then like I
have the upper hand cuz we've already
had sex so I already screwed you what's
something every aspiring songwriter
should know songwriting is a intimate
job and you have to keep your head down
and you just got to write and write and
write but be strong enough and have the
guts to send it out I know so many
people who write songs that just won't
send it out they'd be like oh I don't
know if they're gonna like this or I
heard Rihanna is working on this kind of
record get it'll do send your work in
don't be afraid have the guts to fail
because you're gonna fail so many times
but that one time you write that song
about a guy and how big his penises
it'll be your first number-one rule boy
did it it's that can you get it up that
song that song made me face so go out
there and put your heart into it
somebody what would people be surprised
to know about pitch-perfect series um
that I'm right now fits perfect for and
I hope they take it surprised and I'm
trying to get a whole lot of stuff so if
you guys just band together yes they
wrote a great pitch for pitch perfect
for and I pitched it to rebel everybody
is on board we just really need to know
if people wanted everybody got a DM
Elizabeth bass don't be like Esther I'm
sorry
that that's a long ass that's very long
they be checking on my reading skills
you once said on Instagram that you
would like to get married and have kids
one day but you have no fear that it may
not happen especially because it's a
statistic of a black successful woman
never get married who the [ __ ] said that
what do you think about those statistics
and very successful black woman I am a
very successful black woman penis is
penis anybody can
on just pick a good one that's it okay
everybody's gonna get married if they
want to get married and just pick a good
penis so what song that you wrote
describes you best s mm you once said
I'm obsessed with creating and directing
film what what that film be like you
know what I really like to tell my story
with Steven Spielberg put that in there
I would like to make a movie with Steven
Spielberg it's kind of giving you like
color purple Meets Lady Sings the Blues
without the drugs so if you could go
back in time to when you first started
with writing songs what would you tell
yourself watch the secret early so I
would tell myself about the law of
attraction wait earlier then I knew it
now but once I learned that thing
sky's the limit not even the sky space
I'm gone no more no more I'm sorry
thanks buzz feet that was a lot of fun
watch song land on NBC
[Music]
[Music]